[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
notre dame will host cincinnati on
saturday with that win brian kelly
became the winningest head coach in
notre dame history with win number 106
breaking the previous record held by
newt rockney the hall of famer brian
kelly joining us on the program how did
you celebrate that victory coach
um bumping
bumper traffic getting out of chicago uh
on our bus uh
you know it uh and uh
deep dish pizza from chicago on the bus
so it was kind of neat because it took
me back to my roots as a division two
head coach bus rides you know it's like
triple a baseball uh we took the bus
back from chicago to south bend and got
a chance to be on the bus with the guys
so uh it was real it felt great uh to be
able to celebrate it on a bus ride back
to southbound with uh with your
teammates and uh your coaches
did how many times have you gone into a
game not thinking you could win that
game
not many uh you know i've coached
you know well over 300 games and
i can't remember many that i've gone in
and said we have no chance of winning
this game um maybe i could probably
count them on on my hand uh where where
i felt like it was that overwhelming uh
odds against our football team and and
now
truth be told uh there were probably way
more many games than that it's just i'm
just not wired that way i just go in
thinking that we're gonna find a way to
win
but at notre dame have you felt like
that if it was a playoff game did you
think oh my god i i don't i don't like
her even though you want to win you you
coach to win but is there in back of
your mind you're like i i hope this
doesn't get out of hand
um
maybe in 2012 the alabama uh notre dame
national championship game i knew we
were in a
you know an uphill climb there we were
only three years in
into rebuilding the program here and you
know we got there quickly uh with with
uh playing for a championship and
you know that alabama team was
obviously one of the best in in
a long long time that that a lot of
things would have had to go on right
there so that was probably the one time
when i was at notre dame where i felt
like
this is going to be an uphill climb and
it's almost like you guys were ahead of
schedule and you got to that national
title game because
you know people talk about okay can
notre dame you know have the speed you
know can they can they match the
offensive and defensive lines of sec
teams and and how do you estab how do
you go out and try to establish that at
notre dame
well we still have to recruit to our
profile and so it's player development
uh it's it's the ability to
um
recruit to notre dame at a higher level
than we had been recruiting up to that
point and then developing your players
over a long period of time and
you know the last two drafts we've had
10 players drafted that's as high as
alabama and ohio state and and and
that's where we need to be to have the
kind of players necessary to compete uh
at that that stage so
it wasn't three years into it that we
were having that kind of depth and
drafts and so
um we knew that we were there early like
you said and it just requires
more time in recruiting uh and you gotta
win right we couldn't just celebrate our
past success
uh we had to win
and and that attracts obviously the the
kids to come to notre dame as well
how long do you plan on coaching
you know i've never said this is the day
that i'm going to stop coaching because
i love
the relationships i love 18 to 21 year
old
players that
are growing every day making mistakes
learning from them
that's what that's what's exciting
everybody was asking me about the
wisconsin win and breaking rocky's
record and i
i totally understand that because it's
such a milestone
but i was i was so excited about some of
our younger players and and how they
grew in that game and that's the honest
truth so that's what keeps me going and
and if i'm
if they're still listening to me dan and
and i'm still excited
um
i'll keep coaching for as long as they
keep listening
how do you keep up with younger kids
like 18 year old how do you relate to an
18 year old
i think you have to stay close to him uh
and you can't be locked up in meeting
rooms you've got to be in the training
room with them you've got to be in the
players lounge in the locker room but
you're not doing tick-tock dances or
anything like that are you no i don't
think you have to but you better know
tick-tock uh and you better know
current trends and uh you know i've got
some college age uh kids myself and
uh i said this the other day in a press
conference when when i hear you know
some urban slang i'll immediately text
my my college age kids and ask them what
that means
just so i can stay current on what's
going on
what coach did you take the most from
try to emulate
uh
you know dan i've been asked this
question a lot
i i don't know that i emulated anybody
as much as you know there were so many
mentors in my life growing up because i
was a head coach at 28 years old and i
was so focused on trying to figure out
you know who i was and what i was doing
um
that i just i would listen to anybody
anybody that i respected whether you
were a coach or not a parent
somebody in our office
anybody that i had respect for i was
listening to them and trying to build my
own
identity and philosophy as a young coach
how important was it to uh schedule a
game with cincinnati
well i don't know that there was an
importance i i i felt
like you know when we were talking about
scheduling future opponents i'm like why
don't we get central michigan where i
coached and we won a championship and
let's get cincinnati and um and get them
on the schedule as well
um
just because i i just felt like a a
sense of you know thank you for the
opportunity that that i got to coach
there um
i'm not as excited about that decision
in playing cincinnati now
um
you know it's a great program and and
luke's done a great job there and
you know it's it turns out now it's
going to be a great matchup
were you a patriot fan growing up
i am yeah and i still am
uh
do you uh have any conversations with
belichick
i do yeah yeah we stay close yeah we've
stayed close over the years how often do
you talk to him
probably
every
every couple of months
and you're talking you're you're acting
like belichick now you're not answering
you know it's not a long-winded question
here brian like
we'll talk about games you know uh you
know he'll text me about how we played
and i'll i'll text him back and and um
you know it's it's football related
stuff certainly um about how we're doing
and and uh
we work a lot together with our
foundations as well and that's really
what's gotten us close my wife and and
uh his fiancee are really close in terms
of working their foundations together so
that's how that relationship formed and
we've stayed in contact because of that
but when notre dame plays navy is he
rooting for navy
he's got a deep relationship with navy
there's no doubt there you know it goes
back with his dad and where he was from
and um
i think he stays out of the the rooting
business he's much more into
how games are played uh tactically
and uh you know and i think you you guys
see that from your perspective too he
doesn't get too emotional about who he's
pulling for as much as how the game's
played
i think he ends up at navy when he's
done with the nfl for some reason i hope
not because we play him
that would not be
that would be one reason for us not to
play baby
and all of a sudden notre dame is taking
navy off its schedule uh no doubt and
you're going to vegas next year
we are we're really excited about that
and i i know you know our
shamrock series which travels around the
country and plays in you know great
venues this venue allegiant stadium and
playing in vegas um
you know we're playing byu it's it's
it's going to be a great uh environment
we're really looking forward to it great
to talk to you and uh good luck against
cincinnati and congratulations
thanks dan thanks for having me on
that's brian kelly notre dame head coach
the uh winningest coach in notre dame
history